ja als der antritt termin kam da wurde
mir erst mal so alles so richtig klar so
an dem tag muss ich rein und
an dem tag bin ich an dem tag ist mein
leben anders ganz anders
35 der tag im gefängnis für die jungen
straftäter in verl beginnt raus geht es
nur mit registrierung
dann geht es zur arbeit
ihre freunde staaten draußen durch ins
berufsleben sie arbeiten in der küche
des nachbar gefängnisses und müssen
schauen nicht den anschluss an das
normale leben zu verpassen sie wollen
nicht dass ihre richtigen namen und ihre
tat im fernsehen genannt werden
da ist ein anderer
dort kochen sie für die beamtinnen und
beamten
leute geschlossen sie können also was
nicht schnell die sind 23 zähler und wir
halt haben so ein bisschen
ist das
abwechslung sie sind hier im offenen
vollzug das bedeutet sie dürfen ihre
zelle verlassen und anderswo arbeiten
ich bin eine beamtin bringt ihnen kochen
bei volvo mit von
yasin und mert beide anfang 20 in dieser
lage das verbindet
ich bin jetzt seit vier monaten hier ich
habe insgesamt drei jahre zählen bekommt
ich habe zweieinhalb jahre bekommen
sondern natürlich bereit - egal was man
egal wie viel man draußen gemacht hat
man bereut weil man halt die familie ist
was ist wichtiger als die familie in
ihrem alter stecken andere finale mitten
in ausbildung oder studium
ja sie hat vorher abitur gemacht märz
realschulabschluss im offenen vollzug
gebiert voran und einmal die woche
gesammelt unterricht machen wir
übertrieben leichte sachen satz des
pythagoras drei dass du so was so
das hat nix aber halt meint leute ja
nicht allein wissen standen dagegen sind
die auch leute die war nicht der schule
vielleicht in der küche arbeiten das
nicht ihr traum doch so lernen sie
wieder diszipliniert ihren alltag zu
leben
proben unter grausamen und so gezeigt
wie man spaghetti selber macht
so was hat man nicht jeden tag auf was
neues heute lernen wir schon mal was
neues
zwischendurch muss man schon auch mal
klare ansagen machen
aber das kriegen wir alles ganz gut hin
die brötchen sind zwar nicht für die
gefangenen doch arbeiten in der küche
hat vorteile
alles was zum beispiel nicht gut
aussieht oder zu groß und so ist es wer
selber mehr freiheiten das bedeutete der
offene vollzug wer sich gut benimmt darf
selbst ein paar stunden in der woche
ganz raus nach hause und doch ist es ein
leben im knast und das heißt ja schon
dass die leute irgendwas verbrochen
haben ich meine ich ja auch so man
bereut alles so hier im endeffekt man
hat doch viel zeit sich gedanken darüber
zu machen ich erinner mich
eingeschlossen war dadurch meine familie
an drei monaten einmal gesehen sie
müssen sich vorstellen dass die tour
halt immer auf ist muss man muss halt
immer wieder zurückkommen wir bekommen
hier geschenkt das vertrauen regeln an
die man zahlen müssen geschenktes
vertrauen und zeit zum nachdenken bringt
das was bereuen sie die taten natürlich
tut es mir leid aber
für der passion
aus den fehlern lernen sie bereuen das
soll ziel der haft sein und jva will
eine perspektive für danach geben wer im
offenen vollzug eine bestimmte stufe
erreicht hat darf sich arbeit außerhalb
des gefängnisses suchen wert ist gerade
dabei yasin hat die stufe noch nicht
erreicht wichtig für beide draußen geld
verdienen
während die beiden brötchen servieren
werden in ihrem gefängnis die hafträume
kontrolliert vom jva-beamten terbeck das
kann immer und jederzeit passieren die
privatsphäre verliert man hier zuerst
risiko kann man hier zwar spielen doch
wenn man zu viele risiken eingeht sind
die kleinen freiheiten schnell wieder
weg
das ist eine typische verstecke für
handys und so weiter
hier werden oftmals unter den betten
handys versteckt aber
sid nordens
fenster stunde ist auch okay die fenster
kann man nicht öffnen und besucht wird
bis in die letzte ritze
das ist keine jugendherberge auch wenn
die türen in der jva aufstehen
und auch das gibt es ein klassenzimmer
für den unterricht jeden mittwoch die
gefangenen fragen immer wieder beamte
auch um rat wie es weitergehen soll nach
der haft in freiheit viele gefangene
viele jugendliche gefangene haben die
schule abgebrochen leider haben keine
berufsausbildung oder sonstiges gemacht
diesbezüglich noch nichts zu so wehrt
nach seinem küchendienst hat er fragen
bei bald darüber entschieden werden soll
ob er an zwei tagen im monat wieder zu
hause schlafen darf ein großer schritt
ich hoffe das geht schnell und das
klappt ja immer wir sind gerade bei der
prüfung die gespräche haben wir schon
geführt mit den fachdiensten und so weit
war uns wichtig direkt arbeiten zu
können geld zu verdienen und dann
komplett selbständig zu werden es ist
soweit ist versuchen sie sich abzulenken
tischtennis stadt land fluss karten
spielen
meistens sind wir dann bei mir im zimmer
weil er hat ja noch keine einzelfälle
viel platz ist auch nicht aber ein tisch
zum essen zum trinken reichlich karten
schwer
er habe ich
im moment geht es nur mit ausgangs
schein raus ein paar stunden die woche
wenn sie nicht die familie besuchen
verbringen die beiden diese zeit
zusammen also ich bin ist auf jeden fall
sehr
abwechslung ist auch so was
von früher früher dass es so nicht mehr
gibt manchmal macht das den beiden zu
schaffen wie würden die leute über uns
urteilen was denken die leute sagen halt
immer schlimmer oder so was in die
richtung wie können sie das einmal
hinter sich lassen und wie können die
freunde draußen ihr leben hier jemals
verstehen
der knast ist eine sehr große schublade
sie haben alles in dieser schublade drin
nur halt die einzelnen fächer lesen halt
die leute nicht die leute sehen hat nur
diese große schublade knost aus der
villa raus nicht mehr straffällig werden
sagt er mein traum ist es einfach wieder
zurück in dieses alte leben wieder rein
alles positive brauchen alles besser
machen doch das dauert noch zwei jahre
wenn es sehr gut für ihn läuft